that's the symbol for gaming you know
the outline of that the joystick
that's gaming now they aren't their
iconic but they were built to last as
well so these are still working
perfectly fine here now you know well
beyond their sell-by date no there's a
PCB and it has kind of a little silver
dome over the contacts so and then the
bottom of the panel there's a round base
to it with little dots on the end and as
you move it it pushes that dot onto the
metal dome that touches the two tracks
together on the PCB and that's your
connection so pretty rudimentary but
actually because of that that's what
makes them quite you know sturdy yeah I
mean that and the plastics in them you
can't break these things very easily
please don't come to try the Atari to
600 Atari VCS Atari 2600 Atari 2600
whichever way you want to say it is an
amazing machine so I was lucky enough to
have exactly this machine the Bennett
own pong console played well again Hong
Kong story is very much much an
Americanism over here they were just
tennis consoles to us but we had these
machines and you could play tennis with
your baton your ball and bat it between
each other that was okay for a little
while but actually after a while yeah so
one Christmas I was very very lucky to
come downstairs in the morning and have
a present there kind of that size which
was one of these in its box with combat
the game that packed with it and it's
the sort of the first console really to
have this idea of having cartridges that
allow you to play different games on it
so with the tennis court on when before
you had like seven versions of the same
game football which was basically tennis
with bits of wool would either end of it
hockey which was like football would be
two bats you know it was all basically
the same this was a microprocessor based
system and what you did is you had these
cartridges that plugged in and they had
a ROM chip inside to contain the code
that was the game so that allows us then
to stick all manner of different
cartridges in there with lots of in
games brilliant stuff
it was pretty limited you know this this
was a very limited consult in terms of
what he could do it's especially
comparison we have today so the graphics
were kind of blocky the sound was very
very limited but actually it has a
really kind of nice iconic sound to it
now the joystick could go up down left
and right and they had a fire button as
well that was useful but that again you
know now you can go always and look
around and you know George I sticks so
to a lot of people it looks pretty basic
but it was amazing
color great games didn't matter they
weren't quite as good as the the arcades
that was irrelevant this is combat it's
in the console to start the game press
the reset anybody that had that will now
recognize that rumble and just feel it
all 70s again and you had these little
tanks you could drive around and fire in
each other and if you got near enough so
two players that's a lot more fun so
you're just going around and avoiding
each other but you had game select so
game select allows you to select
different versions of that game so you
the first one we had just a big field
into tanks and you shoot each other now
we've got these various obstacles in
place and you've got to navigate those
and still shoot each other brilliant
game really very very straightforward
but good fun and I remember playing with
a brother shooting each other the
graphics and the sound rear elevant yeah
you've got another player there it's
about beating that person this is sports
you know you've got to beat that person
you've got to beat your brother so you
know that's combat it was great
packed with the console and was the
first game I ever played on it these
carts cost they were more expensive than
your piece from what I remember at that
time lp's were about five are so
considerably more expensive but actually
if you take that and bring up to today's
money that's more expensive than games
are today so everybody moaning about the
cost of games today needs to think twice
because you know you've got what four K
of code or something
2k maybe in these cartridges you've now
got gigabytes of data so the amount that
goes into games these days what you get
for your money is incredible
back then you were paying more money for
far less but then that's just computing
all over you do have to shut down let's
go through that procedure now right
you yank the cartridge out you put
another one in so they were very
kid-friendly right in that respect they
were they weren't delicate devices that
needed looking after no pact in stone
plastic and shove it in the boxes were a
little bit more delicate and that's
where we struggle because we obviously
want to keep a really nice collection of
the old video games but anybody of age
what was our about seven or eight at
this time trash the boxes so they're
quite hard to find so we've got some
really nice condition boxes for some of
the games and less so for others so
we've got Spacey mode is there anybody
that recognizes that would be playing at
the time brilliantly iconic pac-man
looks far better on the cover than it
does in actual real-life adventure so
this is the one that does feature in
ready player one or at least again in
the book as we know we can't really say
what the films like yep having not seen
it and that's the cover for for combat
adventures quite funny so this is kind
of an arcade adventure so this isn't
about typing in go north go south got a
joystick for that but this is about
finding hidden things finding keys that
unlock doors in castles and the reason
it features quite heavily in the book
ready player one is because of the
secret room so the programmer that
created the game put his name in a
secret room and if you went somewhere
picked up something you could unlock
that room and go and see that that
message and he knew it was there and it
would be um you know a certain amount of
time before anybody really stumbled
across there and when it did come out
there's a hidden adventure wow I've got
to find that so that's what people did
and that's kind of pretty much the ethos
of the film it's all these hidden things
you've got to know stuff you've got a
fine stuff obviously it's all about Keys
unlocking the next level so we now think
of that as an easter egg is this the
first Easter Egg that we know of I'm not
I wouldn't know for sure but I wouldn't
mind betting it's certainly one of the
first I mean people will probably go
back and say well actually little bits
of code hidden in programs has been
there for a long time you can imagine
you the programmer wasn't getting the
attention that he deserved you know a
lot of the time in this industry the
programmers create the games they think
we'd get a lot of credit for that if you
look on these boxes it doesn't
who done anything saris policy as I
understand it was you're being paid to
do this you get your money and then we
release it as an Atari game so in the
story but that wasn't good enough so
there's the secret room in this one
let's go through the power up sequence
so there's the beginning of adventure
just a purple border with a number one
in it so to start any Atari game you
press the reset button so press that we
are this dot that's you I could prove
that because I can move them around look
yeah and we have a key so we can go up
and get the key little bit of noise and
we can take it to that gate because it's
yellow key yellow castle and we can get
in there now we have what could possibly
be a sword or maybe just an arrow so we
can now take that one and we can come
out so you've got to have the right
things at the right time so we can go
this way all but we can't because
there's a wall thing there so now we
have to go the other way
so I think we might need to go and get
that instead and go and kill that dragon
II think don't play this for ages yeah
so there's the original yellow key in
there so we've got to get through this I
think and I can't remember how there's
just a few K of code a couple of K okay
I don't know that makes that game but
the thing is again for me playing this
no I didn't have this one because the
games were relatively expensive but a
friend of mine did so I played it over
his house and it sounds kind of silly
but it did immerse you into a different
world you know I was 11 or something I
don't know so to a kid seeing this and
just being able to explore this world
was huge it was great you know an
adventure I think so a lot of people
means yeah a lot because it was that
first time where you had this world that
you can go explore a lot of other games
you know combat was just on that one
field and you shot things space invaders
just continual hordes of aliens your
shoots it but you could go around
different screens and there are things
to find things to discover things to
explore and that made this quite special
so yeah there were the text adventures
before but if you weren't the more
literary literary type then this was
great this was the the beginning of
arcade adventures
okay so the chip insider is it's quite
similar to other 8-bit microprocessors
at the time it's actually a 6507
processor so it's a little bit different
it was running about one maker Hertz
which was about the same kind of speed
as well the other ones did it had 128
bytes of RAM that's away me yeah it's
not even a kilobyte it's 128 memory
locations you can store 8 bit numbers in
programming these things is quite a feat
really and people are still doing
there's a version of Halo being written
that runs on this it's not quite that
halo you'd recognize but it's pretty
impressive it was a fantastic console
and the first really of its kind with
all these cartridges but then not cheap
either 179 pounds to buy one of these
when they come out this together with
the range of games because so many games
were produced for it
so many in probably you know there's the
story of et which says there were too
many games produced for it really
they were just rushed out to market
bulking dream you know you could just
keep producing these things at infinitum
and and that but that was kind of half
the problem because they relied on that
far too much so the console had a very
very long life and they were not sorts
of games produced some better than
others and but they just thought the
kids were stupid and they were good they
were gonna buy these things and enjoyed
them anyway but that wasn't the case
because as this got older so those kids
and they become a little bit more aware
of what a game should be so yeah they
had its troubles and then and the
industry crashed around it really the
first video game crash was with Atari
and et and all those other things that
were going on and so I'm so bit of a
shame but we're still here the graphics
being drawn and this is the Plex on the
first one I have to set the clay field
up for eight lines or so in this
position the library once set up to draw
it in this position and so on I'm
changing the values that we're putting
in there each time interesting if you
look here it looks like we're a bit late